Okay so, today we are very fortunate to have
Ayelet Waldman here with us to speak. Ayelet
is the author of New York Times best seller
"Bad Mother: A Chronicle of Maternal Crimes,
Minor Calamities and Occasional Moments of
Grace"; "Love and Other Impossible Pursuits",
"Daughter's Keeper" and the "Mommy-Track Mysteries".
Her personal essays have been published in
a wide variety of newspapers, magazines including
the New York Times, The Guardian, The San
Francisco Chronicle, Elle Magazine, Vogue,
Allure, Cookie, Child, Parenting, Real Simple,
Health and Salon.com. Her radio commentaries
have appeared on "All Things Considered" and
"The California Report". The film version
of "Love and Other Impossible Pursuits" with
Don Ross as screen writer and director and
Natalie Portman in the lead role is set to
premier at the Toronto Film Festival in September
2009. Her books are published throughout the
world in countries such as England and Thailand,
the Netherlands and China, Russia and Israel.
So, without further ado, Ayelet.
Ayelet: You gotta tell me what's up with the
guy eating his lunch over there. That's just,
we're just all gonna pretend we're not noticing?
[inaudible response].
Ayelet: Ah, I get it, Hi. Hi there actually.
So thank you so much [inaudible] for inviting
me. I've always wanted to eat in your cafeteria
ever since I saw that Google chef wipe out
so dramatically on Top Chef. Did you guys
see that? She seemed really nice, her food
seemed a little iffy, but I have, I was inspired.
And um, I actually when um, when I tweeted
that I was coming down to the, you know, to
talk here today, I don't know how many people
immediately said are you going to go eat in
the cafeteria? And there are, this is probably
not news to you, but there are a number of
employees of Google who take a photograph
of their lunch every day and upload it to
a flicker stream. [Laughter]
Yeah, yeah, it was a good lunch. I don't quite
know what that says about how much time y'all
have on your hands. But um, alright, so I'm
going to uh talk a little bit about my last
book, which is called Bad Mother. Um, and
in particular, one area that I never get to
talk about this cause I never know whether
any body in my audience will really get what
I'm talking about, so it's a pleasure to be
here and I assume you all are going to understand
what I'm, my reference is. So, when I first
got pregnant with my son Zeke, who's my second
kid, who's 13 years old now, the first thing
I did; absolutely first thing I did even before
I verified that I was pregnant was, I joined
an on-line support group for mothers due in
the month of June, 1997. Okay, so that was
like, totally dark ages, right, way back in
1997. There were no Yahoo groups, there were
no Google groups, nobody had even heard of
you guys. Those were the days when we were
using things like Alta Vista and Ask Jeeves
no less. For navigation through the ether
I don't know how, how many of you live in
the East Bay but there was an Ask Jeeves billboard
up for just forever, long after it became
sort of the poignant reminder of the early
days of the internet. But that's when I joined
this first email group. Um, there wasn't even
a web yet. People were just, people who knew
what the web was were starting to talk about
it, but to everybody else, we just called
it the internet. Um, and there certainly were
not 500 million blogs with information about,
you know, the genesis of toenail fungus, whether
Matt Smith can really step into David Tennant's
shoes, anybody? [applause] Thank you.
[female voice]: He can't.
Ayelet: No, I know, it's a heartbreak. Those
were more innocent times before the proliferation
of Mommy blogs and online parenting magazines.
Andy Lamont was still over at Mothers Who
Think and Salon. Do you remember those long-ago
days when she was blogging about her baby
Sam; and it was before she'd even published
any of those books that made her such a superstar
and um, just to give you an idea how long
ago that was, Sam, the baby, she was writing
articles about because they were not blog
posts then, just had his own kid. Okay, so
that's how long ago we're talking about. Now
I had a group of friends at the time, who
were using email regularly and this was not
common, I mean sure, all of you probably were,
but this was not really common. They didn't
use it as much as I did maybe because they
had yet to quit their time-consuming and intellectually-satisfying
jobs for the more mundane pleasures of killing
time while the baby naps, but there were 13
of us some of us knew each other from Wesleyan
University some had gone to school at Columbia
Journalism School. It was this little, we
had, I had my Junebug list and I had this
little internet group of women who [skips]
most of the group of friends, I don't know
if I should tell you the name of that group,
what we called ourselves. But suffice it to
say that this was a time when Cyber still
had kind of a cache about it and um, the literary
genre of Chick Lit had not taken over the
front tables of bookstores, so if you put
that together you can see what horrible name
we came up for our little group.
Um, my, on all my buddies and I were very
regular emailers. Sometime, each of them shot
off as many as, wait for it, 10 to 20 emails
per day. But, if you're a fast reader and
you suffer from graphomania as I can do, then
13 correspondents just is not enough no matter
how prolific they are. And, I can email with
those women, but we can talk about things
like whether, you know I don't know what my
baby had done to turn her shit that exact
shade of Easter Egg Blue, [Laughter] I know,
right? I don't know, still to this day. It
happened periodically, and no one has ever
understood the genesis of it. But I wanted,
what I wanted, was companionship with women
who were going through exactly the same thing
at exactly the same moment. I wanted the,
I wanted to be around a bunch of mothers whose
babies were going to be born in the same month.
So I joined towards, like I said before I
had even gotten confirmation that I was pregnant,
and this was the listserv expectant mothers
due in June of about 50 women in at the time
that I joined. Over the course of the next,
of that first trimester it fluctuated in size
increasing as more people discovered they're
pregnant or discovered the listserv ebbing
at the eight week mark which, you all probably
know why, some people found out they weren't
pregnant anymore, that first ultrasound.
There were people from all over the English-speaking
world, most of us were American. They were
obviously women of all economic classes, single
mothers on welfare, wives of investment bankers,
waitresses, pediatric nurses, neurosurgeons,
these were some of the few that I remember.
There was almost no racial diversity but with
a few exceptions, all women were white but
in other ways it was a pretty diverse group
of people, right? There was, pretty much anybody
who had a computer who got knocked up in the
September or October [laughter] of 1996. And
as you, I'm not telling you guys anything
you don't I know many of you were also back
in those early days member of those listservs
or are now. It was, for me it these were all
women that I was not likely to come across
during my day-to-day life. At that point,
my life had kind of constricted to this tiny
universe of playgrounds and Gymboree classes
in West Los Angeles. [INAUDIBLE] there was
one woman whose husband left her second month
of her fifth pregnancy leaving her to raise
all five of her kids without any financial
or emotional assistance. That was pretty amazing.
There was a pediatric oncologist who left
her practice when she got pregnant with her,
and here's what we call them, Junebugs, got
pregnant with her Junebug and became the first
and surely the most overqualified lesbian
Brownie Troop leader in Hercules, California.
There was an internet entrepreneur supporting
her agoraphobic DH, I assume you all understand
the reference who, by the time her husband
or her Junebug was born was neither a D nor
an H. And then there was my personal favorite,
the reason I stayed with the group I'm sure
is the poly-amorous frequent poster who just
kind of never understood why her partner's
other partner was not as excited about the
pregnancy as she was. [Laughter] So, needless
to say, I loved communicating with these total
strangers, even as they occasionally drove
me nuts. Come on in and sit down. Because
they were whining about hemorrhoids and breast
tenderness, but I was whining about hemorrhoids
and breast tenderness. And so, it was just
this wonderful way to go online and whine
about hemorrhoids and breast tenderness with
people who cared about my hemorrhoids and
my breast tenderness. Everybody else in my
life kind of rebelled at this soul crushing
self-absorption that seems to come over me
whenever I'm pregnant or alive, but I was
rapt. I was rapt by all of these conversations.
And, um you know, that period of pregnancy
I don't think I'm unique in feeling like it's
a time of your life where you are completely
absorbed with navel gazing obvious, for obvious
reasons, because your navel is becoming ever
more prominent. But you know you spend all
your time that you're not working considering
being pregnant and rubbing cocoa butter all
over your belly so it's nice to be with other
people who are doing the same thing.
So this was a really sweet and supportive
group. Right? We took up a collection for
that mother of five. We bought her car seats
and strollers and everything she needed to
have that baby. Whenever anybody shared bad
news, we were always sympathetic. Um, at that,
those early days, we had yet, most of us to
come across an internet troll. There were,
I think there were just fewer of them back
then. But even in those halcyon early internet
days, we got into flame wars. They were over
the usual subjects and usually anybody who
had spent even an hour on the Mommy websites
knows what they're like; breast feeding versus
bottle feeding, cloth diapers versus disposable,
the safety of anal sex during pregnancy [laughter]
okay that was the poly-amorous mom, although
I'm willing to bet there were some people
who were kind of glad for the sharing of information
on that particular subject. I tried very hard
not to start flame wars myself, but I do have
to admit that I was fairly often the first
to launch a spirited defense of any member
who I thought was being unjustly attacked.
But, like I said, this group never generated
into true hideousness, because, and here's
the most important part, we were not anonymous.
We all used our real names, and I'm sure that
it's possible that there was some Julie or
Joanne who was really a troll named Phillip
wearing crusty boxer shorts and a coffee spattered
wife beater hunched over his laptop in a cockroach-infested
studio apartment in Van Nuys getting off on
pretending to be a 28-year-old Mormon woman
from Salt Lake expecting her third baby on
June 14th, it didn't seem likely. And even
if there was such a troll, that Phillip did
such a good job, you know [laughter] of supporting
us and talking about his baby that it just
didn't really matter whether he was real or
not. We believed it and we needed it. And
we got what we were looking for, we got reassurance
that we were normal, we got someone to listen
to us, we were made to feel, by one another,
that we were good enough. We were all going
to be good mothers, right? Then, after that
initial glory days of early internet, I expanded
my web communities beyond this fairly personal
list and of course the level of discourse
deteriorated. [INAUDIBLE] sense of well being.
[INAUDIBLE] a show of hands. That's it? [INAUDIBLE]
You people must be so busy.
[laughter]. You know they still give great
information, you know you can buy discount
Robeez, those little slippers, but they do
seem to generate all the time and at an ever
increasing into full pitch hysterical battles,
the subtext of which not only do you and I
don't agree with each other but your opinion
[INAUDIBLE] and fundamental idiocy makes you
the worst mother in the world. And it's in
this kind of poisonous sludge in the comments
section that we're all seeing the worst in
people. I will say that some of the [INAUDIBLE]
Urban Baby? I've never, I've never gone onto
the discussion board but my husband did after
he, someone called and said there's some emails
you really need to take a look at this, he
goes in his office, he comes out after an
hour. He's like pale and shaking and he gets
me to promise that I will never ever put my
name into the search bar at Urban Baby. [laughter].
Um, so I got my editor to do it, and she also
was, she's, apparently there's, my favorite
part of all the horrible things they says
is that whenever anybody says anything nice
about me or my books someone always says,
according to my editor, 'Hello Ayelet we know
it's you'. [laughter]. Like I'm spending all
my days on Urban. I mean there was a time
in my life where I probably would have spent
more time on Urban Baby, but not so much now.
So during 2005 and 2006 I had a column on
Salon.com that kinda replaced the Andy Lamont
Mommy column and in that column I wrote on
all sorts of subjects. I wrote on motherhood,
yes, but I also wrote on, for example, my
own mother's battles with Medicare, the rights
of juvenile defendants, how much weight I
gain every Christmas season. I tried to be
timely, I tried to be honest and I tried to
write with humor about difficult subjects.
By the time I published my second column I
had completely stopped looking at the comments
section so many people wrote, and while many
responses were sort of vaguely complimentary,
or even vaguely respectful the vast majority
of them were laced with this unbelievable
venom, this loathing for everything about
me, and I just couldn't stand to read them
anymore. For somebody who writes with so much
narcissistic self-absorption, I am very thin-skinned
and I respond to almost all criticism, at
least personal criticism, by falling into
a pit of self-loathing where I'm convinced
that the person doing the criticizing is absolutely
right, and I am as awful as she, and it's
almost always she, says. So, um, but today,
I'm going to be reading, in the interest of,
you know, full disclosure or whatever, I'm
going to be reading a bunch of hate mail,
hate comments from Salon. [laughter]. I thought
that might be fun. so, here's some of the
things, I went and searched that people said
about me in the comments section. "Yet another
article that reinforces my impression that
Ayelet Waldman is in laymen's terms a freak!
[laughter]. I hope Salon's remittance goes
directly into some kind of trust fund to the
poor kid's future psychotherapy." [laughter].
Here's another one; "Please, with lots of
Es, please, please take her away! She's ruined
Michael Chabon for me. I'll never read another
of his books, ever! I won't be able to, just
thinking of him married to her makes me ill!"
[laughter]. And another personal favorite,
"I always need to take a shower after I read
Ayelet Waldman's pieces." And I assume that
he's going to go into the shower and beat
off because he's so excited about me [laughter]
maybe not. Um, but you know look, just even
reading those now, as I'm doing it as a joke,
but I'm still gives me this, kind of like
ah, in my stomach and I think really, really
shower, why? Um, that was not, obviously,
my first experience with being loathed on
the internet, which is, as you can tell, the
subject of today's little talk. Um I had,
as some of you might have known, might have
ready many, I guess it was about 5 years ago
now. I published an essay in the New York
Times that really kind of brought me, not
a lot of people read Salon, so they were haters
on Salon, but with the New York Times, it
turns out that more than 5 million people
read. And I wrote this essay, I wrote it for
a literary anthology, and we're going to do
a little experiment now. How many of you have
ever read a literary anthology? Okay, so,
this is an educated crowd. That was like six
hands. How many who broke, how many of you
read the whole thing? Yeah. Three. Okay? [laughter].
There's my point. What happened was two friends
of mine were putting together this literary
anthology that nobody was going to read and
they, it was all about motherhood and they
called me and said, alright Ayelet, we've
got mothers writing about divorce, and we've
got mothers writing about having twins and
we've got mothers writing about breast cancer,
but we don't have any mother writing about
sex. And since you're the only person we know
that's having any [laughter] you have to write
about it. And, um I decided that I would for
this anthology that nobody would read and
at first I wrote this kind of Dr. Ruthie how
to maintain an intimate relationship with
your husband when you have 4 children piece.
But the more I got into it, the more I always
can, I can always find that sort of corrosive
sense of ribbon of self-loathing in every
topic and I realized that this whole idea
of my sex life made me feel horrible. It made
me feel like an awful mother, it made me feel
bad about myself, and I wrote about that.
So, I'll just give, I'll read you like the
very just the first couple of sentences of
it so you can see what this essay was about.
In case you didn't read it. I have four children,
four children with whom I spend a good part
of every day bathing them, combing their hair,
sitting with them while they do their homework,
holding them while the weep their tragic tears,
but I'm not in love with any of them. I'm
in love with my husband. If a good mother
is one who loves her child more than anyone
else in the world, well I'm not a good mother.
I am, in fact, a bad mother. I love my husband
more than I love my children. And it went
on from there, and on.
Female audience member: I just have to say
one thing.
Ayelet: Yeah.
Female audience member: We were talking about
your coming here someone mentioned that incident
and then a person who's probably here said,
"I love her husband more than kids!" [laughter].
Ayelet. Well you know, it's interesting, because
that is, I just, just as an aside that, I
mean that's really what it's about. He's a
really great guy, and moreover he's like,
he is an absolute 50% share in the domestic
life of our family. So after this essay came
out in the New York Times and I did not submit
it to the New York Times, they picked it up.
I got, I mean thousands of emails. And among
the thousands of emails were the emails from
men saying, "so how do I, you know, make my
wife a little more like you because I haven't
gotten laid in 3 years. [Laughter]. And, um,
oh and I always wrote to these guys, you know
like they're looking for me to give them some
secret, you know butterfly position or something,
but all I said was, you know, you want to
get laid? Here's a trick unload the dishwasher
my friends. Push the Swiffer around the floor.
There is nothing sexier to a woman with small
children then a man folding laundry. Right?
That's why I'm so crazy about my husband,
because I don't cook, I barely clean, he is,
he not only you know works and has a job,
but he also is responsible for more than half
of the domestic world. So um, when that essay
came out, I mean I had been toiling in utter
obscurity before then, I mean really I don't
even know how many, I think my, my murder
mysteries sold in hard cover about 3,500 copies
each and then a tiny bit more in paper. Really,
nobody knew who I was. And that essay landed
with this kind of hysterical thud. Um, the
first thing I knew about was a friend of mine
called me, so it was in the Sunday Times in
the Modern Love column. So a friend of mine
called me on Monday morning, and she said
don't watch The View. Well, I wasn't planning
on it. Star Jones is taking off after you,
and I thought Star Jones is critizing my marriage,
[laughter]. Star Jones who husband's waiving
that rainbow flag and, but, okay. Phone rings
almost immediately later and it's a friend
of mine calling from a Starbucks in Chicago
and she's like, I don't know what you did,
but the women at the next table are tearing
you to shreds. And one of the things about
having one of those names is that it doesn't
belong to so many people is that all of my
friends all over the country were hearing
people scream about Ayelet, Ayelet or Eyelet,
Eyelet, Eyelet. Um, my favorite story was
my agent who was in the Union Square Cafe
in New York city and was talking to her lunchmate
about the essay and someone from across the
room screamed out, I hate that essay that
woman is a complete, and then there was a
fight! In the restaurant with people taking
sides and it's a very quiet, sedate place
and um, my agent was seriously bummed because
she couldn't go there for like weeks afterwards.
But, anyway, so and, of course, the web went
insane. Gawker began what had seemed like
a 6-year devotion to tearing me to shreds.
Um, I don't know what they said there, but
um, but they were, you know, ridiculing me,
and I actually feel like Gawker is my, every
time I feel like nobody reads me or I'm not
successful or my career has been a failure,
at that moment, reliably Gawker will like
publish one of my tweets in this you know
huge screaming bout of Ayelet loathing. And
it just reminds me that I'm like alive, you
know, and that I'm still out there. But at
least some neurotic envious crazy 22-year-old
writer want-to-be in New York City knows who
I am. Um, Andrew Sullivan, who um at the time
I wasn't so fond of it but then after the
Obama, the election I became very fond of.
He also took off after me and at one point,
so this stuff, there's stuff on the web, there's
emails, thousands of emails. The New York
Times is calling saying they've never had
this much response. It was, they're forwarding
me all these awful and also some great but
lots of awful emails. And at one point my
husband was kind of lying face down on the
bed, moaning. Why? Because he had just met
Grail Markus. Do any of you know who Grail
Markus is? He's one, he's the best writer
about rock and roll in the history of music
writing. He's, he's um, I would says he the
grandfather but he's not that old. But he's
like the first guy who wrote about rock and
roll in this really intellectual but also
fun way and he is an, my husband idolizes
him, and he had just begun to exchange emails
with him and that morning an email had come
in from Grail Markus that was addressed, Dear
Sex God. So, my husband was kind of like,
what have you done to me. And, he just rolled
over and he says, God well, at least I should
be grateful you didn't go on Oprah to talk
about our sex life. And um, that afternoon
I was like, well honey, do you mean what you
said because look who's on the phone. And
it was, in fact, the Oprah show and I did
go to be on Oprah, yes I did. I have nothing
to say in my defense other that I am venal
and I really really wanted to sell books.
And Oprah sells a lot of books. That's why
I went. I also went because they told me that
Oprah was on my side, and I thought I was
going to go on the show and Oprah and I were
going to like have this conversation which
we talked about how great my points of view
are and how brilliant I am and that I was
going to go off and sell 800,000 books and
that's not quite what happened. Um, what happened
was, well start at the beginning, on the plane
to Chicago I got this horrible pimple. Right
here. And, of course I was like in the bathroom
popping it the whole way, so by the time I
got to the set of the Oprah show I've got
this like red zit, like, it precedes me into
the room by a good 3 inches. So all I'm thinking
about at that moment is all, is the makeup
department on the Oprah show going to be able
to spackle out the rest of my face, so that
this zit does not cast a shadow. So I don't
really pay attention to what they're saying
to me, so I don't hear the producers, and
the first thing I really notice that there's
something wrong is that there's this kind
of like yowling noise a sort of hysterical
shrieking and I'm in the green room and it
seems to be coming from the vents. And I looked
at the producer and I'm like what is that
it sounds like the, you know the three witches
over the cauldron passing their eye back and
forth. [INAUDIBLE] we are assembled a group
of 24 women, they hate you, there also seems
to be a [INAUDIBLE] defense attorney, Ayelet,
you'll be fine. So, I go out, so they take
me out on the stage, by the way perfect if
you go look on the web, no zit, no zit, complete,
I don't know what they did, magic, every time
I have a pimple now, I ache for them. [laughter]
Um, they lead me out onto this, this sound
stage and there's like producers all around
me, and as I'm getting on the soundstage,
they're choosing women from the audience who
can sit up on the stage, and one woman flings
herself across the seats shrieking, let me
at her! [laughter]. And that's what I saw
when I got on the stage. It was, it was unbelievable,
I mean these women were so angry, I mean they
were just, they wanted to, they had been like,
you know, blogging about me for 3 days and
now was their chance to tear me limb from
limb. And I, I sat there listening to it for
a little while and I thought, you know what,
I don't need this. I didn't go on Jerry Springer,
my goal here is to sell books, I don't need
to do this. I am out of here. And I'm just
about to like undo myself I'm undoing the
mike when this whole end of the sound stage
opened and in this kind of halo of golden
light [laughter] walks a being, I swear to
God, from another planet. Oprah just is not
human. I mean her head is bigger than a human
head. She smells better than a human person,
her skin is like light from within, it glows
a kind of golden, anyway, I was so, my heart
just stopped. I was like, it was like you
know, like if you were an absolute born again
Christian and Jesus walked into your bedroom.
That's what it felt like. [laughter]. So,
she sits down next to me and she leans over
and in my ear she whispers your husband's
book, the Amazing Adventures of Cavalier and
Clay, is the best book I've read all year.
And what am I thinking at that moment? I am
thinking Oprah Book Club! I am thinking four
children's college educations. I am thinking
I am set, I'm going to be rich, I'm going
to guy a bigger house, it's all. So I am not
going anywhere. And, the whole time she was
like every break we would be whispering together
and we were like sharing little jokes and
the women, and the women are totally tearing
me to shreds. My favorite woman says um, she
raises her hand and says that she has four
kids but she's a good mother and the reason
that she knows this because she never has
sex with her husband [laughter] and on the
rare occasions where she allows him to do
his business, and that is a direct quotation
she watches T.V. [laughter]. Yeah. Okay, so
you and I, we hear that and we're just like,
what? Oprah hears that and this is why she's
actually better than all of us, is she without
missing a beat says, what do you watch? [laughter]
To which the woman replies, Jeopardy. Which,
from now on, every time you watch the show,
and you think about buying a vowel, O, O,
O, it's going to completely change your life,
trust me. You'll never see it the same way
again. Alright, so but, you know Oprah did
agree with me, right? She was on my side and
having Oprah on your side means that all of
the women in the room by the end of the show
it was like a cruise ship, you know sailing
along and it just kind of turns around in
the water and it takes about 45 minutes, but
at the end of the turn they're all like oh,
we love Ayelet. We totally agree with her,
she's the best friend we've ever had. Um,
and just, I think this whole talk is an aside,
but just on another aside, so I get off the
stage and I call my husband and I'm like Oh
my God, Oprah and I connected, in this amazing
way. I mean like I, you know how you meet
someone and you just know you're going to
be friends? I mean we had that kind of soul
connection that bond, and you know dude, you
going to have to learn to play golf because
you're going to be golfing with Stedman while
Oprah and I are hanging [laughter], doing
girl things. And he's like uh-huh. So, I go
home and I write her this letter like Oprah,
you and me and the bond and connection and
the soul mates and the instant and the blah,
blah, blah so blah, and I get this letter
back I swear to God it is mimeographed on
that purple, I swear to you and it's off center
and it says, Dear Guest, thank you for sharing
your story. I know. I know, it's so sad. And,
and I really thought, but then, you know,
just to show you that I'm not a complete moron,
I called up a friend whose book was an Oprah
Book Club pick and I was like Isabelle, Oprah
Winfrey? And she said, your best friend for
48 minutes. [Laughter]. And it's true, and
it I know it was real. I know that I wasn't
the only one in the room, because I think
she felt it, I know she felt it, but only
for 48 minutes. And then I even met her after,
and this was really the soul crushing thing
because I thought, at least I'm memorable,
right, if I'm not her best friend, but I met
her after during the Obama campaign, I'm like
oh, I, and she was like, okay, and clearly
no recollection at all.
Anyway, where was I? talking about hate mail?
Okay, so, right. I was talking about how I
was no neophyte to insults, that I, like,
have been insulted frequently, I live in Berkley,
people! I know what it's like to be the butt
of other people's insults. Um, but there is
something really special about the comments
section of the Mommy Blog. There is something
unique about that vitriol. I think it's like
there's this moment in history, how shall
I describe it, it's as if when, um, the world,
the stars align in this certain way to create
the perfect medium for something. So, the
analogy I like to use is dogs and cars. So
dogs, we have been training canines whatever,
10,000 years I don't know how many tens of
thousands of years. We have been creating
this thing, took wolves and we made them into
companions and this whole thing, right and
we did this for whatever reason, for hunting,
for companionship but, it turned out what,
what a little over 100 years ago, when the
first automobile was created, that the actual
thing dogs were meant to do, the thing that
expressed their soul most perfectly was to
stick their head out of an open window on
the highway and have their tongue waving in
the breeze. Every dog, that's what a dog was
meant to do, that's the perfect expression
of dogdom and I who would have known until
we invented the automobile. And that is what
I feel like the internet is for maternal self-loathing.
I think that we probably always existed. There
was always this kind of you're a horrible
mother, I'm a horrible mother we eat our hearts
out, but when the internet was created, it
was this perfect paradigmatic exquisite universe
of bad mother vitriol. Like, the perfect place
for it. So, like, and I want to be really
clear, I am not a Luddite. I'm not one of
those people who believe that she's allergic
to Wi-Fi. Do you know there are in fact, people
who believe that Wi-Fi is called, gives them
migraines, I don't believe that. I love the
internet. I'm going to read you little list
of recent Google, this is one day's worth
of Google searches, 1 24-hour period, for
you all. This is what I looked up: The maximum
speed of a classic single hull wooden schooner;
current presidential polling for Colorado,
Florida, Ohio and Minnesota -this was during
the election; how incomplete grades are awarded
in Harvard College; who on my street gave
the maximum donations to which presidential
candidate; the hours of low tide in Blue Hill,
Maine on July 4th of last year; the square
footage of the average boxing ring; the hours
of operation of a Two Birds Cafe in San Geronimo;
what percentage of Americans are idiotic enough
to believe that Barack Obama is Muslim; the
cost of custom designed vans; the winner of
last year's National's Book Award; the cost
of a set of sails for above-referenced schooner;
which of Paganini's caprices is more challenging
to play, number five or number 24; the names
of string quartets; the starting time of the
movie The Hulk; the relative merits of local
Ethiopian restaurants; Golden Glove rules
regarding the composition of boxing gloves;
the average weight of 5-year-old American
boys and the correlation of emaciation with
delayed cognitive development -one of my kids
doesn't eat; the efficacy of Cetaphil as a
remedy for lice infestation; whether frequent
lice re-infestation has ever been used as
a justifiable defense in a case of assault;
the cost of a flight between Oakland, California
and New York City; the cost of a flight between
New York City and Bangor, Maine; nutritional
information on agave nectar; and the average
number of puppies in a litter of Dachshunds.
And I don't know if that was complete. That
was 24 hours of my Google history. And, to
further prove that I'm not a Liddite I was
an early G-Mail and Google calendars adopter,
maybe not as early as you people, but I was.
I Tweet, yes, I do, I Facebook and I have
been involved in a myriad of listservs and
on-line communities. One, for owners of Bernese
Mountain dogs; another for devotees of raw
dog food -yes be quiet, I know it's stupid.
[laughter] Myriad lists about the 2008 presidential
elections; one for treatment and caring for
children with ADHD; up-to-the-minute information
and photographs of women's high-heeled shoes;
the side, one devoted to the side-effects
of psychotropic medication; one on writing;
one on skin care; one on the proper treatment
of plantar fasciitis; and I will say that
they all get ugly, all of them. Even, the
raw food one, definitely. They all get ugly,
but the vitriol is the worst of all, when
the topic is motherhood. And, um, I don't
know why that is. I mean, other than that
it's a perfect manifestation of everything
we most hate, I, this kind of nexus conjunction
of maternal anxiety, misogyny, guilt, leisure,
technology, I don't know what it is, but it
is a vial place at times. There is even a
study, it's not just me complaining about
how people h ate me on the internet. The University
of Maryland published a study in 2006 that
showed that women are 25 times more likely
to be the target of malicious on-line attacks
than men. This is true. This, so, it's not
just that the web brings out the worst in
us, it brings out the most misogyny and the
most self-loathing. And like I said, you know,
maybe it's true that women have always been
nasty to one another, on occasion, but, you
and maybe now, you know you used to once have
known somebody to be bitchy about her or at
least know someone who knew her and now, you
can be bitchy about anybody, anywhere who's
involved in any literary community. But, at
the same time, I think I just, I'm almost
afraid to say this. If I have any goal in
the time, in the 30 seconds I have left before
I devote myself to parent-teacher, just to
parent-teacher conference, that's where I'm
going now [laughter] to question and answer,
God. I just want to call for like a, a cease
fire, if possible, just a, or at least a raising
of consciousness that we are doing this to
ourselves and each other and that we're doing
this especially around the topic of motherhood.
And I know, I'm never going to give up on
the web, I mean on and particularly on those
listservs. When I was, when Abe was born,
my youngest, has this jaw defect that meant
he couldn't breast feed and I joined this
listserv called Pump Mom, they're not called
list serves anymore, Google groups called
Pump Moms, and I got more information from
those women than I got from every lactation
consultant -yeah, excellent! Than I ever,
I mean those I paid people a hundred bucks
an hour and got nothing and those Pop Moms
saw me through 6 months of pumping. So, I'm
not saying we need to stop, you know, joining
in these motherhood online communities and
I am just begging, and I know what's going
to happen is Gawker will see this little video
and they'll be like oh Ayelet Waldman, just
like Rodney King why can't we all just get
along. [laughter] But really, why can't we
all just get along? Um so with that I'm just
going to open for comments. If you're my mother
you can criticize me, if you're not my mother
you can criticize me too. Questions.
[Female audience member]: So since the ensuing
time is the vitriol is less frequent?
Ayelet: Against me, personally? Yeah. Weirdly,
yes. Um, well yes and no. I mean Google just
did put Michael and me on named us third most
loathsome literary couple or Gawker, not Google,
the third most loathsome literary couple.
Which I actually, was kind of pissed off about,
because, why, why are we only third, why did,
what did Jonathan Safran Foer and Nicole Krauss
do to be more loathsome than me? I don't think
anything. But, so it still rears it's head,
but mostly I think that there actually has
been a little bit of a shift in how we think
about motherhood, in the time between when
I wrote that essay and when the book Bad Mother
came out, because what I saw a lot of when
Bad Mother, which is just kind of, the book,
the book Bad Mother is really in a way I have
a kind of a perversity. There is this Yiddish
word called "oyftsulokhes" which means, you
know like just to spite you, really. So, oyftsulokhes
you everyone gave me grief for this essay,
oyftsulokhes. I'm going to write a whole book
on what a bad mother I am. [laughter] See
what happens then. But actually, it's been
much more positive and I do think it's because
this Good Mother paradigm, that kind of, you
know the aggressive imposition of the perfect
mother image on women has, there's been a
little bit of a backlash against it. And I
like to think if I've done anything in my
literary career, it's going to contribute
to that backlash, so that, um so that now
I have noticed that the women showing up at
the bake sale with the perfect cupcakes, she's
the one embarrassed now. So, which I think
is all good. Can I ask you a question? How
come so many people at Google wear Google-labeled
attire? [Laughter]
[Off microphone]: It's free. It's comfortable.
Ayelet: It's free. Excellent. I don't notice
any Google attire in my schwag bag, but I
don't know. Fleece vest. Anybody else?
[off microphone]: So I was not a mother when
your article came out so I don't know the
controversy.
Ayelet: Uh. Huh.
[off microphone]: Of course I'll go look it
up when I get back. What were people so upset
about. You read that intro and so.
Ayelet: Why, why do they get so angry?
[off microphone]: What were they so angry
about?
Ayelet. You know, it's so interesting, I think
it, I had a conversation with a friend of
mine's who's a, writes for the magazine section
of the New York Times named Lisa Belkin. And
she wrote a piece oh probably almost a decade
ago, maybe 6 or 7 years ago about, it was
a cover magazine piece about um, privileged
mostly white women going back to work; leaving
work and going back home. Like you know, all
these successful women leaving their successful
jobs and becoming stay-at-home mothers. I
don't know if any of you remember that piece.
And she got so much grief for that. I mean
hate mail and so much of it. There was this
one ridiculous instance where her mother was
the dean of a college was sitting in the college
cafeteria and these two women were like, raging
about how Lisa, and they said, "She's just
jealous because says, she's just a stay-at-home
mom." And her mother -because she's her mother-
couldn't resist said excuse me, "My daughter
writes for the New York Times Magazine. She
actually writes cover pieces. They don't usually
just let you do that if you're a stay-at-home
mom, in your pajamas. Yeah, that's actually
a career people." Idiots. But anyway, when
I was talking to Lisa, I asked her why she's
not hurt these people got so angry and she
said thought that she had had this experience
that anytime you write about women of our
generation, women in their 30's and 40's now
into their 50s it's like you're writing a
Rorschach blot. What you say is nowhere near
as important as what they are experiencing.
They like, they read they're lives and a criticism
of their lives. Everybody is so knotted up
with this sense that they're screwing up somehow.
That they read anything as an indictment.
And I think you know, they're probably, you
know so what am I writing? I'm writing like,
hey I'm gettin laid, you're not gettin laid,
and why is that. I mean that's already offensive
you know, like I. Well, I'm not, just because
I'm not getting laid, doesn't mean I'm not
better than you. You know. So I think there
was a little bit of that but I think fundamentally,
any time you talk about parenting, the, we
as readers tend to look on those, those words
as somehow personal attacks. It's not just
that somebody else lives her life, it's an
indictment of the way we live our lives and
we're so anxious and neurotic about that in
particular, that it's a causes this kind of
eruption. The only thing I can think of, otherwise,
who cares, really? You read something by someone
disagree with and you think, ugh, what an
idiot, and move on. I actually had a woman
come to me at a book signing a year after
the essay had come out and said, my husband
made me come. And this was a book signing
where you had to buy the book for $25 and
have lunch. Like you had to be in my presence
for an hour and you had to pay $25 bucks.
That's not nothing. Right? And she said um,
she said my um, my husband because he says
I won't stop talking about you and I've been
so obsessed with you and so angry that he
just felt like I needed to finally confront
you. And I'm just like, what is your? Get
Over It! You know, God. Okay, hate me, whatever,
but really, is it really so important. But,
I do think it's that element of, you know
of just writing, writing this Rorschach blot.
They were just reading something, they were
reading something other than what I had written
or what I had written had triggered something
in them? Yes, anybody? The men, both men,
we should call on them. Ooh three men. Yes,
sir.
[off microphone]: I just wanted to ask you
sort of a man related, your husband Mike writes
essays about men and.
Ayelet: Fatherhood.
[off microphone] Fatherhood. Does he get any
of the same kind of?
Ayelet. Oh, no! He's God incarnate. Michael
writes, it's the same this as like, well he
is a father, right? My, my favorite story
is when he's standing on line in a cafe, he's
got the baby in a baby Bjorn and he's just
getting coffee. That's all he's doing. Not
paying attention to that baby, he is getting
coffee, right? Getting coffee. He might even
spill the coffee on the baby, [laughter] who
knows. And some woman taps him on the shoulder
and she's like oh, you are such a good dad.
And I'm like, you really, what would you have
to do as a mother to have someone in the street
tell you you are such a good mom, and I know
what it is, okay? You have to perform an emergency
tracheotomy with you Bic pen on one kid, while
breast feeding another [laughter] and helping
the third with their homework. Then you'd
get the good mom thing. Other than that, nothing.
So his essays, and yes he's a better writer
than I am. Maybe that has something to do
with it, but people are just like, Oh he's
so wonderful. He's such a great dad. And he
can, nobody ever gives him grief for revealing
stuff about our children, even though he does,
and, it's just so unfair.
[off microphone]: You mentioned, you talked
about earlier one of the reasons you thought
the listservs, the original listservs, to
be more civil was because people were under
their real names.
Ayelet: Yeah.
[off microphone]: [inaudible]
Ayelet: Yeah. The New York Times, well see
the New York Times letters were primarily
positive. They were overwhelmingly positive,
really. The stuff that you, that actually
went to the New York Times, where you have
to sign your name, was mostly fan mail. Its
the stuff that comes to me that could be anonymous
that was so loathsome. And the stuff that
went on the comments section. So I just think
anonymity has a lot to do with it. I mean
look, if you come up to someone's face and
say my name is Ayelet Waldman and I think
you're fat and ugly [laughter] is really different
from like, it's 2:00 in the morning and you're
in your pajamas and my name is Badmomma and
I think you're fat and ugly. It's just a lot
easier to do that, so, I think anonymity plays
a large part in it. But I do think there is,
I mean there has been this, you know, disastrous
thing that's happened to civility. I mean,
I there are a some people who say awful things
on the web who are awful people. I'm sure
that's true. But, there are a lot of people
who say awful things on the web who are not
awful people and there's just something about
that environment, that stew, that toxic sludge
that is contagious. I mean, I know that I
have participated, like I said in inflamed
battles, and then I found myself saying, what
are you doing, did you really say, and then
I have to go apologize. Like one time I, no
I won't take the time, but, you know, so I
think, I do think this, this, there's something
particular about the web and anonymity plays
a large part in that that makes it so much
easier to be your worse self. Anybody else?
Yes.
[off microphone]: So, I'm just curious about
that. The essay, the problem with that.
Ayelet: Um hmm.
[off microphone]: Was it that you didn't love
your kids enough?
Ayelet: Well no it was.
[off microphone]: Or was it you loved your
husband too much?
Ayelet: That bothered people, in particular?
[off microphone]: Yeah, what was the thing
that bugged 'em?
Ayelet. Well, I mean I think there was one
line that was particularly problematic. I
had just finished writing this book called
Love and Other Impossible Pursuits, the one
that's going to be a movie staring Natalie,
it is a movie staring Natalie Portman, out
sometime before the end of the year in your
local theater. It will probably be there for
a minute and a half, so go that weekend. It's
a fabulous movie.
[off microphone]: [inaudible] by Sandra Bullock.
Ayelet: Yes, that too, but it's.
[off microphone]: [inaudible] movie?
Ayelet: It's a great movie too, do both, do
both, great movie. Um, what was I saying?
[off microphone]: The one sentence.
Ayelet: Oh, so the one sentence, so I had
just finished this book and and that's the
book about a woman who's baby dies of SIDS.
And I had been immersed for a year in this
world of like, of maternal grief. What does
it feel like when your baby dies. And what
I wrote in that essay was that while I could
image, like I could, I could run a movie,
I always run these movies in my head, sort
of the worst case scenario movies and all
these terrible things that happen, you know
every time my kid goes on a bike ride I'm
you know is there a child molester down the,
and I could run these movies of their death.
While I can could run that movie in my head
and see the other end, I had no, I have no
capacity to imagine what my life would even
be like without my husband, like I can see
having a life, God forbid is what I wrote,
but I can't see that, without, if my husband
had died. And I think that it made people,
that it felt to people that I was saying I
would throw my kids in front of the bus to
save my husband's life, which I obviously
wasn't saying. And also, there's this great
quote by Nietzsche. You didn't think I was
going to quote Nietzsche did you, but I am,
[laughter]. Um, it requires a shattering exaggeration
for the world to hear even half the truth.
And I think that part of what I was doing
in that essay. Like, you know, I was responding
to this thing that I saw and so my response
was, do I really love my husband more than
my kids? No, you know, how do you compare
that? I don't want to sleep with my children.
I don't want to have sex with my children
or sleep with them frankly, but [laughter]
you know, and I do want to have sex and sleep
with my husband. So you just like varied different
kinds of love and you can't compare them.
So, really that's sort of the truth, but what
I was responding to was a world of hierarchies
and that's why I spoke in a language of hierarchies
and that's what, I think made people so angry.
Let's take one more question and let's let
you people go back to work. Someone be the
last question after I've said this.
[off microphone]: I really about the Rorschach
comment about how people hear and I feel like
no matter how carefully I couch things the
other mother is -we don't watch TV in our
household- the reason we don't watch TV is
because my youngest before she could read
could identify words like 'Lexus', BMW and
Porsche. This child is just, she sees brands
and she consumes them. We watch movies, we
do computers, we not such purists but we don't
want that. This other mother was going to
have them all over and my kid is younger and
they were all going to be watching TV and
it's TV for 13 year olds my kid is six and
I'm like, "Well you know", and I say, "Here's
the [INAUDIBLE] that's a problem. So we don't
watch a whole lot of TV with her. Well she
sent me an email saying that they watched
"The Simpsons" last night. It was a special
episode about Jerusalem and they had a really
important family conversation about it. That
she can't wait until her youngest is old enough
to watch "The Simpsons" so they can all share
that together. And, in fact, she thinks "The
Simpsons" I quote, "is a national treasure".
Ayelet: I mean I think "The Simpsons" is the
national treasure too, but do I feel like
there's anything wrong with it? You mean,
but that's just it, what she heard was not
my daughter is such a nut job that we can't
watch T.V. otherwise she's going to be like
insisting that she get Captain Crunch for
breakfast. What she heard was, what's wrong
with you, that you let your children watch
T.V.? And that's what we always hear, right?
We don't ever hear this is how I do things,
we hear, you're doing it wrong. And it's just
crazy. It's crazy. I don't know how to make
it stop, because I do the same thing, I swear,
if you, my kids um only watch T.V. on the
weekends, but they're allowed to watch whatever
they want. If you, I feel so guilty about
that, I bet I would have been like, "The Simpsons"
is a national treasure! [laughter] Or, I would
have felt it in my heart, but because I'd
written this whole book urging people to put
breaks on their internal, you know, not to
say bad things only about themselves in public
then I would never have said it. But it, it's
like that thing, you know and I missed this,
it's all about her own anxiety, it has nothing
to do with you and your kid.
Um, so thank you all for coming. Thank you.
I have to give a special shout out to the
men in the audience, just because oh my God,
how brave and wonderful. [Laughter]. Um, or
else, just how lazy, and you really didn't.
Or, you wanted to know how to get laid, and
you thought this would be the perfect opportunity.
[Laughter] I have they're mostly home cleaning
related, so come and see me after. Thanks,
guys.